so i i think i'm fortunate in that um
all my stakeholders today i'm
right half of them i'm actually i would
say i'm friends with
so
we're very locked in and i understand as
they make the decision what's happening
so
um i do understand when they actually do
take an action but i'm not really
satisfied with just knowing that they
they took an action what i'm trying to
figure out right now and if anyone has
thoughts on this i'd love to have a
conversation later is um
if you make a prediction that there is a
problem that is going to happen or
service level performance is going to
deteriorate
that prediction is out there you have
stakeholders or operators or whoever
that has access to that information
if you don't know specifically what
they're doing right they could be having
calls with people they could be turning
dials that you don't even know about in
the background
is there a way
that over time you can log your
historical data right your historical
predictions and then over time you can
look at what actually materialized is
there a way
and i i really think it's
regression modeling to say
based upon what we see in these groups
where we are predicting performance
deterioration compared to the whole
we
we can estimate that the predictions are
having the intended effect
right i think it's really comparing a
few different groups there over time as
long as you are cataloging the
predictions you are making
can you formulate that into
um
into a way to quantitatively measure the
impact
so to answer your question number one
in my current situation i'm so looped in
with the stakeholders that yes i know
when they are making decisions numbered
but
i don't know how to quantitatively
measure it yet which leads to number two
i'm trying to figure out ways to
quantitatively measure it